ah mais tout le monde l'a compris c'est
c'est stupide comme si c'est stupide
extraordinaire merveilleux
merci extraordinaire public merde
nous reste pour la gueule mais il était
le spectateurs
il fait la gueule
hey salut il fait la gueule parce que ça
lui coûte du pognon l'émission et vous
savez que il est un peu
demandé à son chauffeur ce matin il y
avait Marcel son chauffeur il avait la
casquette un peu sur le côté alors Guy
descend il fallait rembourser on a la
casquette de côté Marseille lui répond
15 ans de service et tout ce que j'ai pu
mettre de côté
c'est trois mecs qui arrivent ils sont
pétés comme des cochons enfin il y en a
deux qui tiennent encore à peu près de
beau il y en a un troisième entre les
deux qui est complètement ivre mort
il arrive dans un bistrot et
et toi inch'Allah
donner
donnez-moi
un
cours
de coca il sort il est dans la rue
je voulais
je voulais pas croquer
je voulais un cognac
mais qui rentre dans le bar et il tape
sur le bar et
garçon
il est dans la rue
[Rires]
je voulais pas cognac
je vais rentrer dans le Var et je vais
gueuler
rentre dans le bar il ouvre la porte il
gueule garçon un cognac
alors finalement
il réussit à boire son cognac et garçon
un autre dis mais je vais pas continuer
à te servir comme ça c'est complètement
bourré je
suis pas bourré du tout
regarde
tu vois le chat qui rentre dans le bar
et la deux yeux il n'a pas 4
et le chat il rentre pas il sort connard
alors
du coup
du coup il a son il a son deuxième
cognac il est ivre pété mort rond comme
une queue de pelle péter comme un cochon
il sort dans la rue il y a un réverbère
il cogne il tombe il se relève il se
cogne il tombe il se relève il tombe il
se relève il se cogne il tombe il arrive
par terre
alors c'est Joseph Joseph
on est mal payé
qui arrive dans un restaurant parisien
et faites un repas copieux avec sa femme
Lucette arrive le le serveur qui le dit
Monsieur prendrez-vous du fromage et du
mois
de fromage le maître d'hôtel arrive avec
le chariot de fromage le type peut dire
l'heure écoutez je vais prendre un
morceau de chèvre un bout de camembert
un petit morceau de refaire et un bout
de rempli
un bout de chèvre un bout de camembert
un bout de Roquefort et un bout de camp
mais d'ailleurs on n'a jamais eu de vous
n'avez jamais eu des
vous savez au moins ce que c'est le
ramper c'est plus du nom comme fromage
ça on l'a jamais eu mais ça existe
depuis la nuit des temps le Grand Prix
même sous l'Évangile on avait déjà dû
remplir sous l'Évangile
Jésus-Christ puis le vin le pain et le
rompit
ça
se passe sur l'aéroport du Bourget où il
y a un grand meeting et toutes les
grandes compagnies aériennes sont
réunies pour savoir quelle est la
compagnie aérienne qui va réussir à
construire le plus grand Boeing alors
les Américains air panams se lèvent
prend la parole
mesdames et messieurs maintenant
à bord du nouveau Boeing
777 nous allons installer à bord du
boring à ring the box avec autour du
ring de boxe 15000 places assises de
manière à ce que quand on aura lieu le
chaos personne ne sera exactement où il
se trouve dans les airs au moment du
chaos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons installer un bon type Boeing
interne de football avec autour des
terrains de football 150
000 places assises
[Applaudissements]
qui se lève le délégué belge
alors ça je dois dire que vous me faites
doucement rigoler ah oui moi je vais
vous dire moi il me revient une anecdote
en tête soit tu es encore la semaine
dernière j'étais encore en compagnie du
commandant de beurre juste un calva
nous étions en train de faire un dernier
vol d'essai enfin n'essayer une dernière
fois de voler
c'était d'abord d'un Boeing
je sais même plus le numéro tellement il
y avait de 7 de 0,27 on avait rajouté un
drapeau derrière pour mettre le dernier
allez nous étions en train de piloter
comme ceci tout simplement quand tout à
coup je l'entends qui me crie en live
une fois ce que tu sais entendre le
bruit qu'il y a dans le bon sens j'ai
dit mais tu sais 18 réacteurs ça a
toujours fait un peu de pétard il me dit
non j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un bruit
en plus il me dit j'arrive l'impression
que ça vient du bout de l'aile droite
est-ce qu'une fois tu sais aller voir en
bout d'elle droite
je fais en bout de droite pour ce je
prends la foule
une demi-heure de route plus tard
j'arrive en boule dès le droit de je lui
passe un coup de téléphone en lui disant
les vieux tu sais que le bruit ne vient
pas dans les droites et me dire revient
au poste de pilotage je retourne la
poste de pilotage il y avait pas 10
minutes que j'étais assis d'un coup il
me dit
monsieur que si le bruit ne vient pas de
l'aile droite ça vient de l'elgo une
fois voir je redescends dans la soute je
vais en bout de gauche je reprends donc
le folk
25 minutes de route plus oui c'est plus
court d'un côté que c'est de l'eau
sérieusement ça doit ça doit être pour
ça qu'on tourne en rond chez nous
d'ailleurs 25 minutes de route plus tard
j'arrive en bout de la gauche je l'ai
dit morlave tu sais que le bruit ne
vient pas de l'aile gauche non plus et
me dit ça aurait pas crève revient en
poste de pilotage il y avait pas 10
minutes que j'étais installé en poste il
me dit d'un coup
si le bruit ne vient pas de les droites
ne vient de l'ego s'assure que forcément
le bruit vient de la queue alors je
descends en bout de queue je vais en
bout de queue pour ce je prends la
Porsche
1h15 de route oui normalement c'est
juste
une heure
mais on est pour le péage alors vous
avez été obligé
é j'arrive en bout de cul et arrivant au
bout de que j'aille trouver d'où venait
le bruit alors je lui passe un texte oui
parce que le téléphone ne passe pas avec
le décalage horaire forcément alors je
lui passe de télé disons en live stop
j'ai trouvé stock d'où vient le bruit
stop il me répond d'où vient le bruit
stop je lui dis mais le viens le bruit
vient du fait qu'une personne a oublié
de fermer la fenêtre des toilettes un
Jumbo Jet est rentré il ne sait plus
comment sortir
[Applaudissements]
il s'éclate comme un fou il va donner un
piano
c'est c'est une histoire qui se passe
tiens ben voilà tiens allez pour toi
celle-là ça se passe dans un bal
populaire et juste avant de rentrer sur
scène dans les coulisses l'orchestre
répète et on entend un
il a chopé un gamin de 5 ans et il est
en train de mettre des grandes tags dans
la gueule
mais tu es fou tu vas le tuer qu'est-ce
qui t'a fait il m'a déréglé une corde de
là-bas mais c'est pas grave si il veut
pas me dire laquelle
c'est une histoire qui se passe dans une
clinique dans une maternité une femme
est en train de mettre au monde un
enfant et au moment où l'enfant voit le
jour
il n'a pas son premier cri à la place de
crier
il swing
[Rires]
[Musique]
vidéo
alors c'est vrai qu'on est un petit peu
surpris parce qu'un gamin on s'attaque
le mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on l'envoie à l'école on a essayé
de l'envoyer voir des toubibs on
l'envoie à l'école et à l'école c'est
une catastrophe parce que chaque fois
qu'on lui pose une question on attend
une réponse claire et le mot
[Musique]
boire un grand professeur et dans la
salle d'attente c'est pareil le mot mais
il savait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le rendez-vous a lieu
le docteur examine le gamin et on ne
comprend pas d'où ça vient un gamin
swinger alors le lit écoutez madame on
dit aux parents
je ne saurais être de bons conseils
suivant mon idée allez voir un exorciste
alors on emmène dans une église on prend
rendez-vous avec le curé et pendant que
les parents discutent avec le père le
gamin se balade dans l'église
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il arrive au bout de l'église il arrive
dans devant l'hôtel et là il y a le
Christ et il s'arrête net
il est là subjugué par la vue du Christ
derrière le Christ il y a un grand
vitrail
et à travers le vitrail une lumière
céleste envahit l'église
de gamins et là il regarde
subjugué par la beauté de la scène
et d'un coup il se met à faire
merci
c'est chaud un public catholique soit un
public de jazz là
c'est un type qui cherche du travail il
lit les petites annonces et il voit
marquer zoo de Vincennes cherche emploi
facile bien rémunéré le mec qui se
pointe il va voir le directeur il fait
bonjour je viens pour c'est la petite
annonce un eh ben écoutez c'est très
simple le gorille est mort la semaine
dernière c'était l'attraction principale
du zoo et je dois dire que sans le gris
le chiffre d'affaire est en danger on a
gardé la peau du singe
votre tâche est simple vous revêtez et
vous enfilez la peau du singe vous vous
mettez dans la cage du singe et vous
faites le singe 8000 francs par mois
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
ouais prends la peau du singe une
fermeture éclair le masque il est là
et au bout de trois quatre jours mais le
mec ça le fait chier ça le fait chier le
singe devient neurasthénique qui
s'ennuie il est là malheureux le
directeur vient de voir pas du tout je
vous double votre salaire je vous donne
16000 francs par mois mais faites-moi un
singe qui soit heureux de vivre
pour 16000 balles par mois le mec il se
sent plus ils sont ils courent ils
montent au barreau il redescend il prend
une hyène tellement il prend des noms
ils passent par dessus son gris ça
grille et pend il tombe dans la fosse
aux lions
oh le mec il se met contre le mur
à ce moment là il y a un lion qui arrive
qui ouvre une de gueule l'autre
il craque il fait maman à ce moment-là
il y a le lion qui fait ferme ta gueule
on se laver tous les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces deux qui jouent à cache-cache
il y en a qui colle moi je me cache si
tu me trouves tu niques si tu me trouves
pas je suis dans le placard
pour le sport sans le sport c'est une
raison de vivre ça surtout un mode de
vie important sans le sport moi je fais
le sport je fais tout le sport je fais
presque tous les sports
dernièrement j'ai fait le ski nautique
parce que chez nous on a découvert la
campagne alors qu'on a commencé le
skinnotique faut pas croire que c'est
une chose facile nous on avait trouvé un
lac avec une pente il y avait une pente
d'enfer alors j'avais chaussé le Bazin
j'ai été parti droit dans la pente
c'était ma femme regardée faisait les
photos alors moi j'étais comme ça je
descendais plus je descendais plus je
prenais de la vitesse plus je prenais de
la vitesse plus j'allais vite
envoyez vous le problème c'est qu'en bas
du lac il y avait un bar
ça sent pas tellement été le choc sur le
barrage qui a été douloureux voyez-vous
ça plutôt été le passage dans la turbine
oui
c'est aussi dangereux que la plongée
sous-marine quand on sait pas nager
moi j'appelle le sport moi le cheval
aussi j'aime beaucoup le cheval c'est un
sport super ça
écoute j'étais dans le box en train de
choses de sceller le bazinc là il faut
lui mettre un truc avant démonter sur le
cul à se Bourriquet c'était comme ça en
train de le sangler arrive à un type mon
pote péteux prétentieux les bottes le
demi melon la veste rouge comme ça la
baguette là
il arrive il m'a dit excusez-moi
monsieur de vous déranger mais il me
semble que vous êtes en train
d'installer la selle devant derrière
devant derrière
mais comment se tue je veux aller lui
non
par contre le vélo ça le vélo c'est pas
stop
populaire moi dès que j'ai tout
l'équipement je fais le vélo c'est sûr
j'ai presque tous l'équipement je l'ai
pinces à vélo j'ai la pompe à vélo j'ai
pris le vélo de ma belle-mère mais le
plus dur à trouver c'est une casquette
avec la visière derrière c'est la plus
difficile mais dès que j'ai la casquette
je commence le vélo
préféré c'est quand même la pêche oui ça
la pêche à la ligne ça super ça avec mon
ami Albert on va souvent sur la rivière
on loue un bateau et il rame
c'est faux ce qui peut ramener ce garçon
derrière et puis alors chaque fois qu'on
trouve un bon coin hop on le marque avec
une croix sur le bateau
oui bah je sais c'est stupide
comme si c'est stupide parce que si un
jour quelqu'un loup notre bateau il va
nous piquer tous les coins
ça suffit
pas parce que c'est risqué la pêche
surtout avec les bateaux de location
poulet le bateau poulet heureusement
calbert il a les réflexes il a pris il a
pas gay là il a fait un trou derrière
pour que l'eau de devant sort par le
trou de derrière ah seulement la flotte
là elle est rentrée des deux côtés et le
bateau il a coulé et puis quand on a
touché le fond on s'est aperçu qu'on
avait pied heureusement
on ne sait pas nager
aucun des deux choses qui m'a beaucoup
plu voyez-vous c'est que la semaine
dernière j'ai enfin pu réaliser à un
rêve un rêve d'enfance oui j'avais fait
mon baptême de l'air ah oui puis c'était
un forfait intéressant voyez-vous parce
que il y avait donc compris dans le même
forfait baptême de l'air premier saut en
parachute plâtre et séjour clinique
compris
ça t'intéressant alors j'arrive sur
l'aéroport où j'étais invité
l'examinateur en femme instructeur là le
professeur le pilote enfin le charlatan
il arrive comme ça il me dit écoutez
c'est simple on va vous mettre le
parachute quand l'aiguille indique le 5
vous tirez la poignée et vous descendez
comme une fleur je dis moi ce pas un
problème je suis monté dans le bonheur
il a décollé la lumière inclinait j'ai
ouvert la porte j'ai sauté
et c'est là que ça a merdé
parce que quand l'aiguille est arrivé
sur le 5 j'ai pris la poignée j'ai tiré
la poignée et la poignée mais rester à
la main alors moi sans parachute juste
avec un sac à dos je descendais je
descendais vers le bas
quand tout à coup je vois arriver une
dame rapide comme une fusée mais dans
l'autre sens elle montait
Berlo alors moi amis chemin j'ai juste
eu le temps de lui dire
vous y connaissez quelque chose en
parachute elle m'a répondu non pas du
tout et vous en poil Amazon
on va le refaire plus monter allez pour
ce quitter une coquine
si demain ça se passe encore dans le sud
de la France
chez moi
c'est de marins c'est deux militaires
qui viennent de fêter la crise oh
la fête mais alors une quille d'un père
il finisse dans un état ils sont
fracassés mon pote j'aime pas non plus
il fait beau alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
les commentaires quand fait-il comme ça
on se voit de finir au allez
avons plus tard et voilà qu'ils arrivent
dans un dans un dans un morceau dans un
bordel ils prennent la Canebière en haut
de la Canebière et rue curieux là à
l'époque il y avait des maisons encore
dites close
il rentre là-dedans l'autre il se prend
les pieds dans le paillasson et
s'accrochent au rideau le rideau se
casse la gueule sur le vase le vase il
tombe dans la sono oh la mère
maquerelle elle voit ça elle fait ah ils
t'ont fait les filles il y a danger
les gonzesses derrière la mer maquerelle
la mère macrale 1 m 20
les filles ne prenons pas de risque dans
l'état où ils sont ils verront pas la
différence on va leur filer des poupées
gonflables
qui partent avec le casse-croûte
gonflable sous le bras
mon chacun dans une pôle lendemain matin
il se retrouve alors raconte-moi
j'en peux plus
hein
l'hélicoptère chinois j'y étouffé et toi
moi j'ai pas tout compris
j'ai été de surprise en surprise et bien
raconte-moi un bébé hier soir déjà la
première surprise c'est la manière que
j'ai emmené la gonzesse à la chambre
vu que la gonzesse était déjà à le P je
me suis dit père dans pas de temps
j'enlève les fruits pour faire le gamin
je prends deux pas de là je saute par
dessus le lit je dis je vais tomber
dessus mon cul ouais pendant j'y
retourne à côté
j'escalade le lit par la façon non je me
retrouve parallèle à elle dans la
position du tireur couché
et j'ai la santé la grossesse tu vois
molassone pas motivé tu vois la gonzesse
en fin de journée tu vois j'ai dit bon
je vais te montrer qui je suis et
j'avais un temps de dire que les
gonzesses pour les exciter il faut leur
lécher l'oreille
je tire-lait chez l'oreille
troisième surprise j'avais le doigt dans
l'autre oreille avec la langue je me
suis touché le droit
et tu me crois ou non
si je m'arrête pas j'y arrive les amis
d'abord
je me suis dit attends je vais attaquer
les repos
je prends le gauche dans la gueule
oh ça surprend quand même alors j'ai
joué 10 minutes
au bout de 10 minutes de la gonzesse ça
ne se réveiller pas à gigiata je vais te
l'entreprendre là j'ai commencé à y
faire des bisous le long du ventre
direction le nombril et un moment il
s'est craqué puis j'ai pris les boules
je le retour mais j'ai mordu le cul
cette conne elle est partie ainsi font
pas la fenêtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]